drone avion F35 char Merkava dans sa
guerre contre le Hamas palestinien
Israël a sorti les grands moyens on dit
d'elle que c'est l'une des armées les
plus puissantes au monde est-ce vrai de
quelles armes disposeent--elle quelles
sont ses forces et ses
faiblesses en 2022 Israël a consacré 23
milliards de dollars pour ses dépenses
militaires ce qui représente 4,5 % de
son produit intérieur brut et fait
d'elle le 15 pays consacrant le plus
d'argent à ses forces armées vu son
nombre d'habitants un peu moins de 100
millions c'est un effort considérable le
budget de l'armement par habitant en
Israël atteint 2500 dollars près 2300 €
et à titre de comparaison si la France
consacrait le le même montant par
habitant les dépenses militaires
annuelles de la France dépasseraient les
150 milliards d'euros contre 49
milliards en en 2022 l'armée israélienne
bénéficie d'unun budget très conséquent
pourquoi parce que Israël est un état
qui se considère en guerre depuis des
décendies depuis sa sa fondation
quasiment donc il a toujours beaucoup
investi pour sa défense son budget est
en plus renforcé par le soutien de son
allié stratégique les États-Unis
concrètement dans quoi cet argent est-il
investi l'armée israélienne est une
armée complète elle dispose de toutes
les capacités d'une armée à la pointe de
la modernité elle peutêtre surtout une
aviation qui est très conséquente avec
plus de 340 avions de chasse dont des
F35 donc des avions américains qui sont
à la pointe de la technologie et grâce à
ça Israël a une supériorité aérienne
face à tous ses concurrents régionaux
les forces israéliennes sont aussi doté
d'hélicoptères d'attaque et de drone
allant de simples appareils de
surveillance à des engins armés sur
terre tsal peut se venter d'avoir un
nombre considérable de tanks le pays
possède notamment de 2200 blindé c'est
c'est 10 fois plus que que l'armée
française à cela il faut ajouter pièces
d'artillerie donc de char de de de
combat vous avez aussi les fleurons de
l'industrie militaire israélienne
notamment la défense antimmissile à
travers le le bouclier antimissile
multicouche notamment le le dome de fer
et son système antimissile Arau Israël
est une nation moderne très
industrialisée avec des entreprises de
défense très performante en terme de de
drone de cyber de de renseignement et
donc
Israël a une qualité technologique très
importante et c'est son armée qui en
bénéficie et surtout Israël est une une
puissance de thé même si ce n'est jamais
assumé politiquement tout le monde sait
qu'Israël détient l'arme nucléaire et
donc ça lui confère ça lui permet une
supériorité par rapport à tous ses
voisins sa puissante infanterie
mécanisée compte SEP brigades d'environ
3000 hommes chacune elle comprend des
charmer cava des blindé Namer ou encore
des bulozer blind enfin la force navale
s'appuie sur 6 sous-marins 14 navires de
guerre et 48 patrouilleurs et bien sûr
sur l'unité d'élite de la marine
israélienne sa force spéciale chaytê et
puis tsal a une particularité le service
militaire obligatoire pour les femmes et
les hommes l'armée israélienne est très
conséquente puisque l'armée estactive
compte plus de 170000 militaire quand on
on additionne armée de terre marine
armée de l'air et aussi plus de 400000
réservistes ce qui permet en cas de
crise comme on le voit aujourd'hui de
gonfler les effectifs d'arriver à une
suéité numérique sur le terrain depuis
l'attaque du 7 octobre tsal a rappelé
350000 réservistes outre sa technologie
et son budget quels sont les points
forts de tsal d'abord c'est le modèle
sur lequel elle est constituée c'est une
armée qui qui fonctionne selon le modèle
de la la nation en armes donc avec un
lien très fort entre les soldats et la
population civile chaque famille a des
enfants qui sont sous les sous les
drapeaux et israël est un pays qui par
ailleurs est né dans le fracas de la
guerre et qui a dû combattre depuis sa
création en 48 une succession de de
guerre de haute intensité de guerre
asymétrique d'attaque terroristes en
tout genre c'est en quelque sorte le
laboratoire du terrorisme international
malgré toutes ces forces sal a été pris
au dépourvu par le mass lors de
l'attaque du 7 octobre l'opération
nommée déluge d'alaxa a notamment donné
lieu à la destruction partielle de sa
barrière de sécurité à 1 milliard de
dollars aussi cette guerre asymétrique
qui est menée contre les adversaires
d'Israël et la symétrie c'est quand on
nivelle par rapport de force en ayant
recours B à du combat en zone urbaines
au souterrain en se mêlant à la
population civile tout ça efface une
partie de la supériorité militaire que
peut détenir Israël ensuite la dernière
faiblesse d'Israël c'est un excès de
confiance parce que justement Israël
pensait être hors de danger de ses
concurrents de pouvoir gérer la menace
et on voit bien que ce n'est pas
forcément le
cas